[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com alright welcome to the bonus
show I'm here hat is here as you can see
and we are both here we've got our split
screen up I think everything's working
so far it's always a question mark Pat
when we have like anybody is not in
their usual spot but right now
everything I think is working pretty
well yeah and you have that evey
microphone with you that we're used to
hearing yeah instead of that blue Yeti
that was you know a little bit cheaper
but that was like your your go-to for
the remote setup right but I think we've
really perfected the remote setup now
like this is this is great well so
normally when I do the show somewhere
else oh and now I'm seeing my entire
room is actually very very bright let me
see I'm actually gonna do a live
adjustment let's see if I can do this
that a leaf blower I'm hearing there we
go no no leaf blower thankfully um but
no actually know what that is that's my
laptop fan which you can hear but mic
fortunately is not picking up because
it's a proper proper microphone so
normally I bring like a USB camera and a
USB mic because of size if I'm from the
standpoint of luggage if I'm flying you
can't bring everything I've got a full
voice processor my entire mic arm a full
size camera I mean it's crazy the amount
of equipment I have because now I'm not
flying and this was a very very
straightforward driving trip I was able
to essentially bring my full set up I
mean I don't have like my full lighting
but I have the microphone I normally use
I have the equipment I normally use so I
think that this is a really really great
way to go yeah especially for the
podcast that imagine that the audio
audience isn't even going to notice a
difference you did say at the top of the
show that you're broadcasting for
Martha's Vineyard yeah but aside from
that they probably wouldn't even know so
here's the deal in in Martha's Vineyard
um everything I've been doing has felt
totally safe in the sense that it's the
same stuff I've been doing in Boston
where I mostly just at home and cooking
at home I'm seeing very few friends and
it
always in outdoor settings I'm wearing a
mask any time I go to the grocery store
I'm wearing a mask when I pick food up
now the the difference here and this is
just a frustrating thing is that this is
a popular New Yorker and New Jersey
vacation spot
and so I I really want to be I don't
want to be unfit I don't want to be
stereotyping and in fact there are some
friends of mine from New York that are
coming here after I'm going to be gone
and they're going to be totally safe in
every way but strictly speaking if
you're coming from out of state you're
supposed to quarantine for 14 days no
one's doing that I mean most people
don't come for 14 days so that's just
okay that's out the window you can still
be behaving responsibly otherwise but I
was in what I would say is the most
obnoxious sort of part of the island
from the from the perspective of the
people is Edgartown there's like three
Martha's vineyard's tiny there's three
towns Vineyard Haven Oak Bluffs and
Edgartown Edgartown is like the most
annoying to me pretentious place and it
was filled with families of seven in
huge SUVs with New York plates who would
get out in the most crowded area the
island is not crowded in general right
but they would like Edgartown can be
crowded they get out no wearing masks
and it's just like that to me makes me
think that you know how I say the rules
are there for the two percent of people
who don't have any common sense I feel
like it's that 2% that might screw
Massachusetts and we've been doing so so
well yeah I feel as though people were
abiding by the mandatory two-week
quarantines at the beginning of all this
so like if they were coming from China
or if they're coming from Europe in
February or early March we I think for
the most part people were willing to
abide by those rules because the cat
wasn't yet out of the back but now we
get 40,000 new cases confirmed here in
the United States every day and people
have been dealing with the virus for
months and months it's already a reality
for us so sure there are gonna be some
people who are responsible but then
there are gonna be others who just don't
pay attention to those rules yeah and
I'm
listen I get it like if your vacation is
to go to Martha's Vineyard for a week
you're not gonna go and quarantine for
14 days I understand that but the you
know that you've gotta wear the mask
you've gotta do the other stuff
something insane happened in Edgartown I
actually posted this to my Instagram
there's a so in general you you can
either fly into Martha's Vineyard or
take a ferry the most common ferry
leaves from Woods Hole Massachusetts and
if you want to go then from Martha's
Vineyard to Chappaquiddick you have to
take a subsequent ferry it's like a
small it only fits two to three cars at
a time and a few people and in Edgartown
yesterday there's like a nice lookout
point I was up there with my girlfriend
we were by ourselves I was just watching
the ferry watching the water and then at
a certain point a woman comes up with
her boyfriend and she's just holding her
phone up with no mask holding her phone
up in front of her face like this stands
three feet behind me and because she's
filming not only does she have no mask
she does she has no way to cover her
mouth and she just sneezes right into
the air three feet behind me and my
girlfriend and it's like with everything
that's going on right now that's what
you're doing why are you even three feet
away from me at this point in time now
hopefully she didn't have the virus in
an outdoor setting like that she wasn't
pointing at me it would be insanely bad
luck that the wind blows enough virus
into my respiratory system I get it but
it's like what the hell are you doing
dude you have no idea what's going on
right now yeah and I remember early on
when they started to say wear a mask
they were saying this is not a
substitute for social distancing you
still have to social distance and so
that happens to me sometimes where even
like I'll be wearing a mask and the
other person is wearing a mask but we're
still too close and that just irks me
the wrong way yeah it's horrible I have
a very similar story from over the
weekend which is that I was near someone
who was wearing a mask but then they had
to cough and they took off the mask took
off it's like that's the point of the
mask just coughing - the mask it's okay
right well and again depending on the
type of mask you have it may prevent
particles from going through or not but
no matter what you're better off right
like it's the mask is something rather
than
thing and still listen when we read that
report that like 80% of cases came from
9% of the people I understand why as
soon as you venture out in public you
and understand why but moat for the most
part I'm just by myself with my
girlfriend and we've been seeing one
other couple who is also very safe who's
also on the island staying somewhere
else the beaches I've been going to
literally have no one on them like
yesterday I was at the beach and there
were three other people 50 feet away or
something out even a hundred feet away
something like that so it's all it's all
feeling pretty safe but definitely from
what I'm seeing and the anti mass
Crusaders that now are floating around
like I don't think I'm that at first I
was really bummed that summer travel was
essentially kiboshed
now I'm just kind of grateful that I
don't have anything booked where I feel
the pressure to go because it just it
just doesn't seem safe there's too many
more moronic people floating around
there yeah and it really is becoming
political who wears the mask and who
doesn't wear the mask yeah and I think
that goes to the point about how
conservatives often times have an
empathy gap like we saw that with the
gay marriage debate a few years ago
where many conservatives were against it
until they found out that a family
member theirs was gay yeah it's kind of
the same thing with the masks where like
they don't have a sense of like if you
if you wear this thing it's protecting
other people it's not just about you
it's not just about you not wanting to
wear it it's about protecting those the
people around you it's just it's just
common courtesy right I mean if you go
out in public there are certain things
that you do you stand in a line if
there's a line for something right you
don't cut it yeah you maybe hold the
door open for someone just just be a
nice person right this is one of those
things you can do to be a nice person
wear the mask so let's talk about a
couple of new stories that are relevant
and an interesting one is that comedian
Sacha Baron Cohen did another one of
these stunts which I find absolutely
hilarious and now has right-wingers
falling all over themselves to claim
that everybody knew that something was
wrong and nobody was really cheering for
what Sacha Baron Cohen was doing Sacha
Baron Cohen went to a gathering of the
three percenters and I believe it was
Olympia Washington and through you know
he never reveals his methods fully but
basically used some intermediaries to
get himself booked as an additional band
to perform at an event at this event and
he was in full costume where he had like
sort of like a fat suit on and a beard
and different hair it looked like a
completely different person and he went
up there and he sang an absolutely
insane song about with rhyming that
involved blame Obama for the Wuhan flu
all sorts of racist and xenophobic
things people from the video I saw Pat
did seem to be singing along but now
that it's gotten out that it was Sacha
Baron Cohen the organizers of the event
are saying we never approved this we
were tricked as soon as we realized what
was going on we tried to remove him from
the stage but his own security blocked
us from removing him they want to make
it seem like nobody in the crowd was
going for the stuff but I don't know in
the video it seems like the crowd is
loving these chants about Obama and the
Wuhan flu it's kind of hard to tell
because it does seem like someone from
the audience just filmed Sacha Baron
Cohen up on stage so you don't really
see the audience reaction if this is
part of a second season of who is
America then I'm sure we'll be able to
see who in that audience was enjoying
themselves and also singing along yes oh
yeah I love his tactics honestly because
like he started out the song with saying
things that were like yeah I kind of
edgy but not too over-the-top and then
by the end he was saying that we need to
like chop up Anthony Fauci and we need
to like I don't know just horrible stuff
that people were like singing along to
about the end because it was just a
catchy song and they were like enjoying
the lead up to it yes as the lyrics got
worse and worse people just follow it
along and that's it's like very
interesting thing that happens if he had
started with like the craziest stuff
maybe they wouldn't but because he like
led them into it they went along with it
one interesting detail that is that is
leaked is we sometimes wonder you know
when Sasha Baron Cohen gets himself into
these potentially dangerous situations
like once for a movie I believe it was
either in Alabama or Arkansas he showed
up in his sort of more flamboyant gay
character and was doing I don't remember
what but there was like a real risk that
things could get ugly
and in this particular case it was
reported that they had an ambulance on
standby driven by his team so that they
could get out
and nobody would be like get the black
sedan it would just be like an ambulance
and it would be much less likely to
cause a problem for him getting out
which is an interesting security detail
that it had not occurred to me yeah my
favorite Sacha Baron Cohen skit was from
the first season of who is America and
he dressed up like a liberal do-gooder
he was wearing an NPR shirt and he a
ponytail and he went to a really
conservative area in Arizona yeah and
proposed to everyone a new mosque for
their city yeah and it would be like the
biggest mosque outside of the Middle
East and it was just so hilarious to see
these right-wingers react to it their
minds is really funny and then what I do
you know a lot of this stuff is staged
this type of not Sacha Baron Cohen a lot
of people who do things like this it is
staged to some degree it really appears
from the reactions and the statements
that are made by the people that he
pranks that they are not in on it
like at all and to me that makes it good
you know a lot of the prank calls that
we sometimes hear more recently there to
some degree staged and if indeed the
stuff Sacha Baron Cohen does it is not
staged that that really makes me think
of it as far more clever than some of
the other things we're seeing I'd
imagine he also filmed some skits that
maybe don't go so well where people
discover hey this is Borat dressed up as
a different character so for those they
don't use I remember there was a big
story about Sarah Palin who gave an
interview with Sacha Baron Cohen and
then later found out who the guy was and
I don't think they ever aired that
interview maybe because it didn't go
well maybe because they just thought
that they wanted to avoid a lawsuit I
have no idea why they decided not to but
yeah that sometimes just doesn't go well
but you don't see those I want to talk
briefly about the fight for statehood
that is happening in Washington DC I had
a few friends over the weekend posting
some things on Facebook about Puerto
Rican statehood that's one issue that's
been discussed quite a bit the house has
actually passed a bill which would make
Washington DC the 51st state in the
United States now the democratically
controlled House passed it the
republican-controlled Senate is of
course not going to pass it they are not
even likely to take it up this is
essentially dead in the water for as
long as Republicans
the Senate my question though is Pat if
indeed Democrats took control of the
Senate
I believe they still wouldn't be able to
pass it because wouldn't it either by
default or through some finagling
require a supermajority in the Senate
anyway thus taking control of the Senate
still would not get it passed it
definitely has to be a priority for Joe
Biden pass it through the house pass it
through the Senate make DC a state make
Puerto Rico a state then we'll have four
more senators and it's going to be hard
for Republicans to gain back control of
course that's like the real sort of like
political motivation for doing it yeah
for the left but there are some real
issues at hand as well like how people
in DC pay income tax but don't have a
voting representative in Congress so and
you know how other other countries they
may have like a district a federal
district as their capital but those
people still have full-on rights like
they can still vote they could still you
know get representation and all that
stuff it seems like with DC there's this
really second-class citizen thing going
on that we have to get rid of I saw a
very interesting series of tweets I it
was an argument I don't remember between
who it was being some left-wing or in
some right-wing politician and the
right-wingers said you know if we did
this with DC it immediately gives two
senators to the Democrats and the
response was instead of trying to
continue bit blocking DC from having
representation why not figure out how to
get Republicans to win those
hypothetical seats like it exposed that
it's a foregone conclusion that
Republicans don't even imagine that they
could make the case that they should be
the ones representing Washington DC like
in their mind it's just you know that
they like to claim that their policies
are better for people if that's the case
you should at least pretend to believe
that you could convince DC voters hey
vote for us instead of just voting in
two Democratic senators they don't even
mention it you're right if it was up to
me I would say abolish the Senate
because it's so undemocratic you have a
state like Wyoming that has two senators
again they have 600,000 people living
there something like that in any of
California that is what 3040 million
people in the state and they also have
two senators so that's already
inherently there
very good for the Republicans I saw Tom
cotton railing against DC statehood no
look what kind of arguments is he going
to try to make one of the arguments he
made was that the new map of what the
the new federal district would be
because it would really just be like the
white house in the capital National Mall
yeah was too ugly and that had had 19
sides to it and they just didn't like
how it looked so that was one of the
things another argument that he made was
so disingenuous he was trying to act as
if this would allow the swamp to get
more representation like you know these
two senators would just be representing
like lobbyists and that sort of thing I
think he's just trying to like trick
people maybe many of its constituents
back home and Arkansas don't realize
that like DC as a very high black
population many of those people don't
work on Capitol Hill and you know
they're just like living their lives and
it's just a normal City and I don't
think that maybe he was able to convey
that at all like he was trying to trick
people's and yeah I mean it's like DC is
of course filled with restaurants DC is
filled with schools DC is filled with
museums and NGOs and it's and
everybody's not working in government
and the idea that it's mostly government
workers government jobs it's a joke and
and by the way the idea of the
gerrymander errs in chief saying DC
shouldn't have senators because the
shape of the represented area would be
ugly is I mean you've you've got to be
catering to people that are too dumb to
know better right because that's just
ridiculous and another argument I heard
was that he was trying to counter the
whole taxation without representation
thing yeah by saying that for every
dollar that DC residents pay in taxes
they get $4 back well that sounds a lot
like red states yeah most of the red
states are taker states that they they
they pay less in taxes than they receive
in taxes so does that mean that maybe
they shouldn't be states either should
we strip statehood from them because
those are the taker states - it's just
it's not a sound argument
none of these are sound arguments it's
absolutely ridiculous and I - go back to
what you first said I believe that if
Joe Biden does become president DC
statehood should be a priority
absolutely and I'm personally I'm for
Puerto Rican statehood as well I think
it's less of an obvious case I believe
they deserve it no doubt
I think the DC case is just so obvious
that it should be done and used as
precedent to then whoa as I hit my
microphone to then talk about Washington
DC alright my microphone I just punched
and it is now it's just totally flaccid
and falling apart so that is the one
downside of being out of the studio the
range my punch range for the microphone
is modified but I will try my best to
have that reconfigured for tomorrow
thank you for joining me I'll be coming
to you from Martha's Vineyard for the
remainder of the week it is a huge week
it's just an incredible week that we
have going on and we will have much more
coming up for you tomorrow the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]